intentan salvar sus cultivos del impacto
de la crisis climática a veces es el
frío otras veces son las altas
temperaturas las que acaban con más de
la mitad de sus cosechas los
agricultores de esta ciudad al norte de
egipto han tenido que improvisar sobre
la marcha ante los bruscos y repentinos
cambios del clima ahora decidieron
cultivar especies foráneas de mango
añade a comenzamos a cultivar mangos que
originalmente no eran locales para
adaptarse al clima como crimson naomi y
yasmina estos tipos de mango coinciden
con el clima actual soportando altas
temperaturas y también el frío manejar
este mapa de la temperatura de la
superficie terrestre de la nasa muestra
como en el último mes parte de eeuu el
norte de áfrica medio oriente y el sur
de asia han registrado altas
temperaturas y aunque la temperatura de
la superficie terrestre no es lo mismo
que la temperatura del aire conocer qué
tan caliente está la tierra permite a
los científicos e investigadores saber
qué tanto pueden resistir sus cultivos
frente al cambiante clima el málaga
ahora el clima está cambiando es inusual
por ejemplo podemos pasar de la
temperatura de invierno a la temporada
de verano y viceversa y esta condición
extrema está gravemente la producción de
mango en toda la meseta
estos nuevos cultivos de mango mantienen
a los agricultores optimistas esperan
que con las técnicas de ventilación los
invernaderos improvisados la poda y los
fertilizantes adecuados la producción de
este año pueda llegar a término